tv.org
okay good I'm Bradley Graham Connor
politics and prose along with my wife
Alyssa Muscatine and on behalf of
everybody at P & P and and the staff
here at six and I welcome you know we at
and P&P been doing these a jointly
sponsored author talks for a number of
years as much as we would have liked to
have had you in our store on Connecticut
Avenue you just all would not have fit
so we are really very excited to be able
to use this spacious and and very
beautiful and comfortable setting for
for author talks like like the one this
evening and what a treat to have to Tom
Friedman with us anyone familiar with
Tom's columns in the New York Times and
his previous books knows how great and
explainer of well just about everything
he is a few people can cut through the
complexities of something and and write
about them as clearly as Tom can he says
at the start of his new book that he
went into journalism in part because he
loves translating from English to
English and that's been very evident and
in his work what he focuses on in his
new book thank you for being late are
several forces that he singles out as
defining the world nowadays and
affecting our lives at dizzying paces
the forces of climate change technology
and globalization he discusses how the
accelerating changes engendered by these
forces are reshaping our lives and how
we can cope with them in thinking this
through
Tom towards the end of the book looks at
the community in which he grew up a st.
Louis Park a suburb of Minneapolis for
lessons on remaining anchored and
connecting with others and trusting and
succeeding a time of course has had a
storied career
a journalist dating back to well a high
school in Minnesota that's when his
passion for journalism was sparked by a
10th grade teacher and when his interest
in the Middle East also was ignited by a
visit with his parents to Israel in
college and graduate school Tom focused
his studies on the Mediterranean and
Middle East so it seemed only fitting
that soon after becoming a journalist he
ended up in that part of the world it
was United Press International that
first sent Tom to Beirut and after he
moved to the New York Times it wasn't
long before they sent him back to Beirut
and then on to Jerusalem his reporting
during those years garnered him - pew
letters for international coverage and
led to his first book from Beirut to
Jerusalem relocating to Washington Tom
was assigned and rather quick succession
- three of the papers top reporting jobs
chief diplomatic correspondent chief
White House correspondent an
international economics correspondent in
1995 that's 21 years ago he took over
the papers Foreign Affairs column and
has been at it ever since winning a
third Pulitzer this one for commentary
in 2002 those who follow Tom's columns
know they're not just about Foreign
Affairs in the traditional sense of
diplomacy and international conflict
they also deal with globalization the
environment finance technology and a
number of other issues relevant to how
the world works today his six previous
books to have exhibited exhibited a wide
range of interests as well as the same
engaging conversational writing style
that has characterized his columns Tom
writes for the general reader and where
and as we're about to hear he pitches
his talks to the general listener - so
ladies and gentlemen please join me in
welcoming Tom Friedman
[Applause]
thank you very much thank you thank you
good the last time I was here my
daughter was here and my son-in-law was
here and there was a hope of here and
they were getting married and they're in
the front row here so it's uh thank you
all for coming out thank you for not
being late it's uh I'm gonna talk
tonight about my book I'm gonna talk for
about 40 minutes to give you a general
overview and then we're gonna we got
microphones in the front and I really
looking forward to your questions let me
get right to it the title of the book
thank you for being late where does that
come from the title actually comes from
beating people in Washington DC for
breakfast over the years as a columnist
and every once in a while someone would
be 10 15 20 minutes late they see Tom
I'm really sorry is the weather the
traffic the subway the dog ate my
homework and one day I just
spontaneously said to one of them if
Peter friend my friend Peter course L I
said actually Peter thank you for being
late because you were late I've been
eavesdropping on their conversation
fascinating I've been people watching
the lobby fantastic and I just connected
to ideas I've been struggling with for a
month so thank you for being late
your people started to get into it
they'd say well what well you're welcome
huh because they recognized what I was
doing was actually giving them
permission to pause to slow down to
reflect that my favorite quote in the
beginning of the book is from my friend
of Seidman who says you know when you
press the pause button on a computer it
stops but when you press the pause
button on a human being
it starts it starts to reflect rethink
and reimagine and this book was really
my attempt to press the pause button on
myself in order to reflect rethink and
reimagine where we are and the book
indeed began with a pause where I
stopped and engaged someone who I
normally wouldn't have and it ended up
through a sequence of events producing
this book so I actually live although I
work for the New York Times some of you
know I live in Bethesda Maryland and
about once a week I take the subway to
work so for me that means driving down
Bradley Boulevard and I park in the
public parking garage beneath the
Bethesda Hyatt and I did that almost
three years ago now when I started this
project I parked there I take the red
line into DC I come back get in my car
I've got my time stamp ticket I drive to
the cashiers booth I give the ticket to
the cashier he looked at it looked at me
and said I know who you are
I said great he said I read your column
I said great he said they don't always
agree I thought get me out of here
I actually said well that's good it
means you always have to check you know
and we both had a laugh and I drove off
week later I took my weekly subway ride
redline into DC back car time stamp
ticket cashiers booth same guys there
this time he says mr. Friedman I have my
own blog would you read my blog I
thought oh my god the parking guy is now
my competitor what just happened
so I said well write it down for me and
I'll check it out so he wrote it down it
was oh he took a piece of cashiers tape
and ripped it in half and he wrote down
oh denim be calm I went home I called it
up on my computer turned out he was
Ethiopian he wrote about Ethiopian
politics from a very democracy point of
view on his own web
and I started to think about this guy
and wondered who he was and what his
story was and I eventually concluded
that this was a sign from God
I should pause and engage him but I
didn't have his email so the only thing
I could do was park in the parking
garage every day so I started taking the
subway every day it was four or five
days I don't remember now how many we
overlapped I parked my car under the
gate I got out I said au lait now I know
his name i le bojayá
invited him tonight but unfortunately
was ill and I said I want your email and
that night I he happily gave it to me I
wrote him an email and I repeat all our
emails in the front of the book somewhat
more funny and I basically said to him I
have a proposition for you I am ready to
teach you how to write a column if you
will tell me your life story and he
basically through a couple of email said
I see you're proposing a deal I like
this deal so he asked that we meet near
his office at Pete's coffee house in
Bethesda which we did two weeks later
and I presented him with a six page memo
on how to write a column and he told me
his life story and it was the first time
I'd ever actually put all this together
I once taught a course on how to write a
column my daughter's college but
actually enlarged it sat down and really
reflected on what it was about his life
story Ethiopian a grim immigrant a
democracy advocate actually a political
exile came here was blogging on
Ethiopian websites but they were they
were too slow so he decided to start his
own blog and now mr. Friedman I feel
empowered
he knows his Google metrics you have to
love a parking guy who knows his Google
metrics and um he's read in over 30
countries this is my parking guy what an
amazing world that he can get his voice
out there that way
so I then presented him with my memo and
we actually went over it three times
three different sessions at Pete's
coffee house I explained to him that a
news story is meant to inform and it can
do so better worse I could write a new
story about six than I but a column is
meant to provoke I'm either in the
heating business or the lighting
business that's what I do okay
I either Stoke up an emotion inside of
you or illuminate something for you and
ideally if I do both I will produce one
of several reactions I didn't know that
I never looked at it that way I never
connected those things your favorite you
said exactly what I felt but didn't know
how to say god bless you
I want to kill you and all your
offspring any in one of these any one of
these reactions will tell you you
produce heat or light but to produce
heat or light I explained to him
actually requires a chemical reaction
and you have to combine three chemicals
the first is what is your value said how
do you lean into the world what are the
ideas you're trying what is the world
view you're trying to promote are your
communist a capitalists a neocon and
your liberal a libertarian a Keynesian
what is the value set you're trying to
promote second how do you think the
machine works so the machine is my
shorthand for what are the biggest
forces shaping more things in more
places in more ways on more days as a
columnist I'm always carrying around a
working hypothesis of how the machine
works because I'm trying to take my
values and push the machine and if I
don't know how the machine works
I either won't push it or I'll push it
in the wrong direction
and all my books really have been a
one-take or another on how I think the
machine works lastly what have you
learned about people and culture how the
Machine affects people and culture and
our people in culture affect
machine stir those three together let it
rise bake for 45 minutes and if you do
it right you'll produce a column that
produces heat or light so the more I
explained this to a healin the more I
thought to myself well if that's what a
column is about what's your value set
where did it come from how do you think
the machine works today and what have
you learned about people in culture and
I decided that was the book I wanted to
write and that's what thank you for
being late is all about so I don't have
time obviously to go through the whole
thing so I'll focus on the core engine
of the book how the machine works today
so I think what is shaping more things
in more places in more ways and more
days is that we are in the middle of
three accelerations one of them is a
exponential they all may be in fact in
the three largest forces on the planet
all at the same time I call them the
market mother nature and Moore's law so
Moore's law coined by Gordon Moore over
50 years ago now the co-founder of Intel
says that the speed and power microchips
will double roughly every 24 months and
while it's probably you know 30 months
now
that is basically held up for over 50
years if you put Moore's law on a graph
it looks like a hockey stick mother
nature for me is climate change
biodiversity loss and population growth
if you put that on a graph actually
looks like a hockey stick and lastly the
market for me is globalization but not
your grandfather's globalization not
containers on ships that's actually
declining digital globalization Twitter
Facebook PayPal all the things that are
now being digitized and globalized put
it on a graph it looks like a hockey
stick
we're actually in the middle of three
hockey-stick accelerations all at the
same time with the three largest forces
on the planet and they're all
interacting with one another more
Moore's law drives more globalization
more globalization drives more climate
change also solutions as well but
they're all whirling around each other I
think that is what's shaping more things
in more places in more ways on more days
now that the real flywheel of the whole
thing really is Moore's Law and that's
why the second chapter of the book so
I'll go through the three accelerations
quickly or actually just the first one
Moore's Law the second chapter the book
is called what the hell happened in 2007
2007 sounds like such an innocuous year
2007 what's this guy talking about well
here's what happened in 2007 the iPhone
came out in 2007 January 2007 Steve Jobs
unveiled it at the Moscone Center in San
Francisco beginning a process whereby we
are putting an internet-enabled handheld
computer into the hands of every person
on the planet but that's not all that
happened in 2007 Facebook came out of
high schools and universities in 2000 -
too late 2006 and became available to
anyone with an email address in 2007 a
company called Twitter which went which
was launched a few months before went
global in 2007 a company not a company a
software called Hadoop the most
important company in your life that you
have never heard of named after the
founders son's toy elephant created the
foundation for big data by creating an
open-source software platform that made
a million computers work like one
computer in 2007 a company called github
also launched itself the biggest now
open-source software repository
in the world with roughly 14 million
users got an idea
no problem just go to the github library
pull it off the shelf use it fix it
improve it put it back on the shelf it
is one of the most important companies
in the world today that's not all that
happened in 2007 in 2007 Google came out
with something called Android in 2007
Google bought a company called
YouTube in 2007 a guy named Jeff Bezos
came out with something called the
Kindle in 2007 IBM started a cognitive
computer called Watson in 2007 three
roommates in San Francisco thought it'd
be a really cool idea to rent out their
air mattresses to some guys coming for a
design conference and they started a
company called air B&B ever seen a graph
of the price of sequencing a human
genome looks like this straight down up
here hundred million dollars down here
twelve hundred dollars the year it goes
over the cliff two thousand seven two
thousand seven something called fracking
started the 2007 look at a graph of
solar energy takes off in 2007 in 2007
something we call the cloud started go
back to the beginning looks just like
that look at the first date 2007 2007
change.org started 2007 Palantir started
in 2005 Michael Dell retired he'd seen
it all in 2007 he decided he had to come
back to work in 2007 Intel for the first
time went off silicon to extend Moore's
law and introduced non silicon metals
into its transistors
turns out friends at 2007 may be seen in
time as the single greatest
technological inflection point since
Gutenberg invented the printing press
and we completely missed it
why 2008 so think about what happened
all right right when our physical
technologies just took off like we were
on a moving sidewalk at an airport that
suddenly went from five miles an hour to
35 miles an hour all of our wuterich
buying Hawker calls our social
technologies the learning systems the
management systems the regulation and
deregulation you needed to get the most
out of this acceleration and cushion the
worst they all basically froze and in
that disjunction we have been living the
last seven eight years think about this
election in the context of 2007-2008 let
me just digress for one moment so in the
50s 60s and 70s if you were a average
worker with an average education high
school or above you actually could get
something called a highway j--
middle-skill job I quote a congressman
from Minnesota I'll get to that later
who said in Minnesota back in the 60s
and 70s you actually needed a plan to
fail okay if you were an average worker
you needed a plan to fail because there
was so much wind at our back so much of
blue-collar work and even white-collar
work that you could get with a high
school degree my uncle who only had a
high school degree working at a bank in
Minneapolis in the 60s then what
happened globalization starts to hit and
technology starts to accelerate 80s 90s
early 2000s what do we do for the
average worker to help them compete we
actually didn't improve education we
gave them credit cards and home
mortgages and a lot of the middle of the
average worker able to sustain
themselves through a huge expansion of
credit and by writing up the values of
their homes
then 2007 and 2008 happened what happens
in 2007
is and I'll explain this just in a
second machines and software now start
ravenously eating white collar and blue
collar jobs at a pace we've never seen
before and people lost their homes
because of the 2008 crisis and that
shock I would argue produce this
election produced a lot of very
dislocated and angry people but I
digress so basically what happened what
produced 2007 was the fact that it
wasn't just microchips that were in a
Moore's law actually all five parts of
the computer or in a Moore's Law
microchips were accelerating software
was accelerating networking was
accelerating storage was accelerating
and sensors were accelerating and in
2007 they all meld into something we
call the cloud the cloud I never used
the term the cloud because it sounds so
so soft so cuddly so fluffy
sounds like a Joni Mitchell song I've
looked at clouds from both sides no this
ain't no cloud folks this is a supernova
supernova is the largest force in nature
it's the explosion of a star only this
is an ever-accelerating supernova and it
has basically two things came together I
was here on this stage around 2005 to
tell the story of a massive collapse in
the price of fiber optic cable it
happened as a result of the dot-com boom
bubble and bust we made fiber optic
cables so cheap we accidently wired the
world and I gave that moment a name I
said the world was flat
because we so collapsed the price of
connectivity that we could suddenly
touch people we could never touch before
and we could be touched by people who
could never touch us before and I wrote
a book called the world is flat
I wrote the 2.0 edition in 2006 I wrote
the 3.0 edition in 2007 and then I
stopped I had it figured out
2007 as my broker says to me a bad year
to stop sniffing glue okay and I
basically stopped in in 2011 I wrote
another book it was here for that with
my colleague Michael Mandelbaum about
America called that used to be us and I
started into itting when I wrote that
book that I had missed something I'd
missed something because I suddenly
realized that when I was running around
the world in 2005 telling people the
world is flat Facebook didn't exist
Twitter was still a sound the cloud was
still in the sky 4G was a parking place
LinkedIn for most people was a prison
applications what you sent to college
big data was a rap star and Skype was a
typographical error all of that had
happened between just 2005 and 2011 of
course only when I wrote this book that
I understand it all really came together
in 2007 and what produced that another
price collapse only this time it wasn't
the collapse of connectivity it was a
collapse in the price of complexity we
made computing and storage so cheap that
we could make complexity fast free easy
for you and invisible think of what it
was to catch a taxi five years ago and
what it is today what you can now do
with one touch
you can page a cab direct the cab pay
the cab and rate the cab masses amounts
of complexity have now been abstracted
away and it's happening everywhere it is
like a phase change from solid to liquid
it's putting grease and leverage in
everything so when you make connectivity
free fast free easy for you and
ubiquitous and you make complexity fast
free easy for you and invisible you get
an incredible release of energy that
changes four kinds of power and that's
what we're now living with it changes
the power of one what one person can do
today as a maker or a breaker is
phenomenal we have a president-elect who
can sit in his penthouse now and on his
iPhone tweet to 20 million people and to
them almost the entire globe unmediated
it's changed the power of machines
machines can now think in February 2011
the world change of all places on a game
show it was called jeopardy they had the
two all-time champions Jennings and
rudder and the third contestant just
went by his last name
Watson mr. Watson passed on the first
question but he buzzed in before the two
humans on the second question and the
question was it's used by a dealer in a
casino and worn on the foot of a horse
and in under 2.5 seconds Watson said in
his unique voice what is shoe oh the
world has not been the same since a
cognitive computer figured out a pun not
what year was America born figured out a
pun faster than two human beings
you changed the power machines it's
changed the power of flows ideas now
flow and change as speed we've never
seen before
five years ago Barack Obama said
marriage was between a man and a woman
today Barack Obama says marriage bless
leaves between any two human beings who
love each other and he is following
Ireland in that think of how quickly
ideas now flow and melt away and lastly
it's changed the power of many we as a
collective are now a force of and in
nature in fact the newest geological era
is being named for us the Anthropocene
so these four kinds of power they aren't
just changing the world they are
fundamentally reshaping the world and
they're reshaping five realms it's the
first part of my book is about these
accelerations and the second part is
about the five realms that are being
reshaped and how I think we need to
reimagine them the workplace is being
reshaped politics is reshaped
geopolitics be reshaped ethics and
community let me go through a couple of
those just to give you a flavor for what
I'm talking about
so my chapter on how the workplace is
being reshaped is called how we turn a I
into I a how we turn artificial
intelligence into intelligent assistance
ance intelligent assistance a NTS and
intelligent algorithms so people can
learn faster and govern smarter to live
in an age when the there is this change
in the pace of change one of the hardest
things for the human mind to grasp is
the power of an exponential and that's
what we're in the middle of my friends
Andy McAfee and Erik Brynjolfsson wrote
a wonderful book called the second
Machine Age like to tell the story of
the man who invented chess very
well-known story gave the game to the
king king loved and said how can i
reward you good sir and the man said I
just want to feed my family well what
would you like the king asked he said I
just like you your hind us to take one
grain of rice put it on the first square
to on the second floor on the
eight of the next 16 on deck just keep
doubling it my family will be fine the
king said no problem it shall be done
not realizing when you double something
63 times the number you get is like 18
quintillion Ann's Andy and Eric point
out we just entered the second half of
the chessboard where the doubling starts
to get really big and you start to see
really funky stuff you start to see cars
that can drive themselves machines that
not only can win at jeopardy but Watson
has now basically ingested every article
written on cancer you start to see
really funky stuff the power of an
exponential is so hard to demonstrate
that Intel decided just to give its
users some feel for this its engineers
on the back of an envelope basically
said what if a 1971 VW Beetle improved
at the same exponential rate as
microchips and they calculated today
that VW Beetle would go 300,000 miles an
hour
it would get 2 million miles per gallon
and it would cost 4 since that's the
kind of exponential we are in and
therefore we're all feeling it the
change in the pace of change in our
workplace I was like to say when I got
out of college I got to find a job when
my girls got out of college they had to
invent a job and I think this is
increasingly going to be true so my
chapter on the workplace is called how
we turn artificial intelligence into
this kind of intelligent assistants
assistants and algorithms the examples I
give are first of all the HR policies of
AT&T big company 360 thousand employees
living on the edge of the supernovae
competing every day with Verizon
Deutsche Telekom you know t-mobile very
interesting to understand what their HR
policy
like so I spent a lot of time with their
HR team quite simply is what AT&T does
Randall Stephenson their CEO begins to
here with a radically transparent speech
now about what world he thinks they're
in what their competitive environment is
like and what skills you're going to
need as an AT&T employee this year then
they put every employee on their own
in-house LinkedIn system then they
looked Brad Graham Brad Graham Brent bed
we have 10 skills we think you need to
thrive this year at AT&T and you've got
seven of them but you're missing three
then they partnered with Sebastian Thrun
of Udacity the online learning platform
and he created nano degrees for all 10
then they came to their employees and
said we will give you up to $8,000
$8,500 to take all these courses on one
condition you have to take them on your
own time if you take these courses our
deal with Brad is that when the new jobs
open up Brad will get the first crack at
them we won't go outside their new
social bargain with their employees is
very simple if you want to be a lifelong
employee at AT&T you have to be a
lifelong learner or if you are a
lifelong learner you can be a lifelong
employee if Brad says you know what I've
climbed up too many phone telephone
poles I'm tired
don't want to take these courses they
have a wonderful severance package for
Brad now but Brad will not be working at
AT&T anymore that social contract is
coming to a neighborhood near you
intelligent assistant what's the example
of that the example I give is Qualcomm
did a lot of work with Qualcomm
again one of the most important
companies you've never heard if they
made all the software for your iPhone so
Qualcomm has a campus of 64 buildings in
San Diego and a couple years ago they
basically retrofitted a bunch of these
buildings with sensors on every pipe
every electric socket every computer
every door of your window every HVAC
system they just have sensors on
everything they beam all that data up to
the cloud and then they beam it down
on to an iPad for their janitors the
janitor is now walking around the iPod
iPad you leave your computer on they
know it that lightbulb goes out they
know it you leave a door window open
they know it and they can also sweep
down find who the repair person is the
manuals all there they've given their
janitors and intelligent assistant to
enable them to live above the line their
janitors now give tours to foreign
visitors now think what that does for
the dignity of that person because
they've now got an intelligent assistant
enabling them to operate at this higher
level intelligent algorithm that's the
my example is the partnership between
the College Board and on Khan Academy so
I see this crowd looks like roughly my
age and my demographic we all have kids
in college we know when they were in
high school they have to take the PSAT
exam and the SAT exam and I know what
you did you hired a tutor to get your
kid's PSAT and SAT score up and you had
to pay some college get 200 bucks like
for two hours in order to lift your kid
above the line a wonderful thing for
your kids for you and me completely
rigged game if you come from a family
that can't afford that you're behind the
eight ball from day one so what happened
is the College Board who administers the
PSAT partnered with Saul Khan from Khan
Academy and they created free PSAT and
SAT prep online now Brad takes his PSAT
exam in 11th grade and he gets the
results back from Khan Academy and it
says Brad Brad you really did well but
you have a problem with fractions and
right angles then it takes Brad to a
website Khan Academy devoted just to
fractions and right angles just for him
tailored to exactly his weakness
if he does well comes back and says Brad
Brad have you thought of taking the AP
maths in your senior year and then
they've got another link that will take
him to college scholarships it's an
intelligent algorithm last year two
million American kids got free SAT prep
through this intelligent algorithm so
what she actually find and you would
never have known it from this campaign
where the biggest idea of Bernie Sanders
was to take down the banks that people
are actually doing amazing stuff to try
to help people live at this higher pace
of change but it's a real it's a real
challenge I'll talk briefly about my
chapter on how we need to reimagine
politics so I believe we aren't just in
the middle of one climate change we are
in the middle of a change in the climate
we're also in the middle of a change of
the climate of Technology and a change
in the middle of the climate of
globalization the reason people feel so
unmoored today is we're going through
three climate changes at once what do
you want when the climate changes you
want two things you want resilience need
to be able to take a blow because things
can get really disruptive and you want
propulsion not be able to move ahead you
want to be curled up in a ball so I
thought to myself who do I talk about
about how we produce resilience and
propulsion when the climate changes but
no and then I realized I knew a woman
she was 3.8 billion years old
her name was Mother Nature and she'd
been through more climate changes than
anybody so I sat her down and I
interviewed mother nature I said mother
nature how do you produce resilience and
propulsion when the climate changes she
said well Tom first of all I mean I do
all of this unconsciously but I'm first
of all incredibly adaptive in a brutal
way through natural selection but I'm
incredibly adaptive only the adaptive
survive in my world second she said I
love diversity a
pluralism try 20 different species see
who wins my most pluralistic ecosystems
are the most resilient ecosystems third
she says I I do believe in
sustainability and the circular
sustainability everything is food for me
eat food poop seed eat food poop seed
I'm very sustainable for she said I'm
incredibly entrepreneurial wherever I
see an opening in nature that's empty I
fill it with a planter animal perfectly
adapted to that niche fifth she said I'm
very patient
you can't build anything resilient
without time you can't speed the growth
of a thousand-year-old baobab tree or
the gestation of an elephant sick she
said I believe in ownership you know
when ecosystem is in balance it really
owns that space it's highly resilient to
invasive species parenthesis the
Republican Party lost ownership of their
eco system and Donald Trump was an
invasive species that came in physics
that's exactly what happened by the way
so lastly she says or 7/8 whatever it is
she said um I believe in hybrid
solutions I mix things I put the right
bees with the right flowers the right
trees with the right soils Andre
heterodox I'm very hybrid there's
nothing dogmatic about me lastly she
said I do believe in the laws of
bankruptcy I kill all my failures return
them to the great manufacturer in the
sky and I take their energy to nourish
my successes well what I did in that
chapter I basically argue is that the
political systems that most consciously
mirror Mother Nature's killer apps will
be the most resilient in the age of
acceleration and then I just for fun
took it one step further and said to
myself what if Mother Nature were
running in this election if she had a
party
what would her platform the
and I invented Mother Nature's political
party and just to give you a sample of
it because it reflects obviously my own
politics because on some issues I'm
actually to the left of Bernie Sanders I
think we should have single-payer health
care system if Sweden can do it and
Singapore can do it I cannot understand
why we can't do it at the same time I'm
to the right of the Wall Street Journal
editorial page I would abolish all
corporate taxes and replace them with a
carbon tax a tax on bullets a tax on
sugar and a small financial transaction
tax I think we need to get radically
entrepreneurial over here in order to
pay for the safety nets we're going to
need over here because the world is
gonna get too damn fast for some people
but to me the two go together
unfortunately in our politics if you're
for radical entrepreneurism you can't be
for safety nets if you're for safety
nets you're deaf diradical
entrepreneurialism that has got to go
that is not sustainable which is why I
believe all our political parties are
blowing up that is what is happening
whether it's in the UK or Europe or here
and the reason they're blowing up is
that they were designed as responses to
the Industrial Revolution the New Deal
the early IT revolution and civil rights
and civil rights and what you have to
respond to as a political party today
are the three accelerations how you get
the most out of them and cushion the
worst let me close by talking about some
ways my my favorite chapter in the book
it's called
is God in cyberspace and the title of
the chapter comes from the best question
I ever got on book to her a Portland
Oregon 1999 I'm selling Lexus in the
olive tree and a man stands up in the
balcony and says mr. Friedman I have a
question is God in cyberspace I thought
I I said I don't know I never been asked
that question before I felt like a
complete idiot so I got home and I
called my rabbi um and one of my real
spiritual teachers at the time and since
named remark she's a great tall Munich
scholar I met him at the Hartman
Institute in Jerusalem and he's married
to a Dutch priest that lives in
Amsterdam he's very interesting guy
and I called him in Amsterdam and I said
see I've gotten a question I've never
got before he is God in cyberspace and
he said to me well Tom you know in our
faith we have two concepts of the
almighty one is biblical one's
post-biblical the biblical view of the
almighty is he's almighty he smites evil
and he rewards good and if that's your
view of God he sure isn't in cyberspace
which is full of pornography gambling
cheating lying prevarication and crazy
conspiracy theories and bad talk but he
said fortunately we have a post biblical
view of God and the post biblical view
of God is that God manifests himself by
how we behave so if you want God to be
in cyberspace we have to bring him there
by how we behave there so I took C's
interview and I put it into the
paperback edition of Lexus and the olive
tree came out in the year 2000 and I
completely forgot about it as I started
writing this book I found myself
retelling that story and I finally set
myself down so why are you retelling
that story and it's obvious and it
became starkly obvious in this election
everything has
to cyberspace how we do commerce how we
educate how we build friendships how we
find spouses how we learn
everything's moved to a realm where
we're all connected but no one's in
charge what does that mean it means you
get fake news
it means the word of the year is is the
phrase of the years post truth means you
can go into a realm now and say anything
about anybody so much of our lives are
moving into a realm where we're all
connected and no one's in charge
therefore values what each one of us
believes matters more than ever
especially when now you can be a super
empowered maker and a super empowered
breaker Oh in the world's good for
makers it's good for breakers so for
those two reasons values
the golden rule matters now more than
ever what every single person believes
now matters so I gave this talk just
about that chapter is the commencement
address at Olin College of Engineering
last spring and I said to the parents I
know what you're thinking you paid 200
grand so your kid could get an
engineering degree and there's a
knucklehead up there preaching the
golden rule is there anything more naive
oh there it is one thing more naive and
that's thinking we're going to be okay
if we don't scale the Golden Rule
naivete
is the new realism you see friends we
stand
at an intersection that the human
species I would argue has never stood at
before a moral intersection in 1945 we
entered a world where one country could
kill all of us
post Hiroshima it had to be one country
I'm glad it was ours I think we're
entering a world where one person can
kill all of us and at the same time all
of us could fix everything with the same
amplified powers we have actually never
stood at this place before where one of
us could fill could kill all of us and
all of us could actually fix everything
all of us could feed house and clothe
and educate every person on the planet
with these same powers what does that
mean means we've never been more godlike
as a species we have never been more
godlike as a species we have never stood
at this intersection before and
therefore what values we have and
whether we can bring those values to
this realm called cyberspace now matters
more than ever
where do values come from come from
places like this whatever your faith is
values basically come from strong
families and healthy communities and
that's why the book ends with two
chapters I don't know but not expert on
strong families I'd like to think I'd
live and build one but I'm not an expert
on that but I am an expert on healthy
communities because I grew up in one I
grew up in an amazing little town slash
suburb outside of Minneapolis called st.
Louis Park I went to same high school
grew up in the same neighborhood with
the Coen brothers Al Franken norm
Ornstein Michael Sandel Peggy Orenstein
Alan Weisman we all grew up in the same
neighborhood at roughly the same decade
and a half
this wasn't a neighborhood in the Upper
West Side this was a one high school
suburb in Minneapolis and I basically
tell its story and the short story is in
Minneapolis and
these the 50s early fifty is the Jews
all live basically in a ghetto in the
north side with African Americans and
the Jews were able to get out in the mid
50s to one suburb the one that didn't
have redlining so basically in a
three-year period all the Jews of
Minneapolis moved to one suburb called
st. Louis Park a suburb that had been a
hundred percent Protestant Catholic
white Scandinavian overnight became
twenty percent Jewish Protestant
Catholic white Scandinavian if Finland
and Israel had a baby it would be st.
Louis Park and it produced this freaky
explosion of energy the Coen Brothers
movie as serious man
was about our Hebrew school if you watch
No Country for Old Men you'll notice in
the scene where a chuga blows up a car
outside of a pharmacy in Mexico the
camera pans up the pharmacies called mic
sauce drugs that was our local drugstore
okay and I tell the story of how we got
to know each other and built an
inclusive community of trust my friend
of also says trust is the only legal
performance-enhancing drug oh where
there's trust in the room in a community
you got people applying the golden rule
I tell the whole story of how we did it
wasn't easy but we did it with amazing
community leaders then I come back 40
years later to my same high school which
is now 50% white Protestant Catholic
Scandinavian ten percent Jewish ten
percent Hispanic and 30 percent Somali
and at a small African American
contingent same suburb that took the
Jews in the 50s took the Somalis in the
90s now the inclusion challenge is so
much more challenging but ain't that the
story of America and ain't that the
story of
the world I left st. Louis Park fifty
years ago to discover the world and I
came back and found the world had
discovered st. Louis Park so I conclude
book and I'll conclude my talk tonight
with the book's theme song it has the
theme song I thought of buying it to see
if I could buy it so when you opened the
book you would play this song like a
Hallmark card plays happy birthday and
the song is by a wonderful singer who I
really like Brandi Carlile a great
country folk singer and her song is
called - I you ie and the main refrain
is I wrapped your love around me like a
chain but I never was afraid that it
would die you can dance in a hurricane
but only if you're standing in the eye
and I believe right now folks these
accelerations they're like the winds of
a hurricane we just elected a man who
thinks you can manage them by building a
wall I don't think so
I think you have to build an eye the eye
that moves with the storm draws energy
from it but creates a platform of
dynamic Stability within it that I for
me is the healthy community and the
struggle in this country and globally I
believe going forward is going to be
between the wall people and the eye
people and I'm for the eye people thank
you very much
[Applause]
oh yeah
thank you
we have time for some questions and
we'll take about ten minutes go ahead
please mr. Friedman I'm a college
student here in the Washington DC area
and have read with great interest
several of your books um my question is
um what are what do youth what do you
think are some of the most meaningful
and important things that you have
learned throughout your career about the
ability that one has to communicate and
educate in the context of writing wow
that's a really good question next
question back there please I know that's
a wonderful question um I'll tell you
the what I've learned most that um to me
the most important lesson two most
important lessons if you want to be a
journalist for me do people come to me
say I want to be a journalist um I say
well what do I need to know I say well
it's really good if you can type fast I
can really type that I went to
secretarial school in London in fact to
learn to type fast um good if you know
some history and literature and
certainly good grammar in English but
there's actually one thing that you have
to have to be a good journalist I
believe you have to like people you have
to enjoy hearing the crazy things they
say and do and people can tell and if
you like people they will open up to you
and they'll really share you know what's
on their mind it's amazing to me how
many journalists hate people and um you
know one of the of the many criticisms
of me out there is that I just talked to
cab drivers okay
I've actually never interviewed a cab
driver um for any of my books but never
mind
if a few more pollsters had interviewed
cab drivers in this last election they
might not have been so surprised because
you don't guess what talking to another
human being
is a form of data and a lot of people
forget that especially today in the age
of big dad the other thing though I
think you really need to be a good
journalist is you have to be a good
listener for two reasons one is what you
hear but the other reason is much more
important
it's because listening is a sign of
respect and it's amazing what people
will let you say to them if they feel
you respect them it's amazing what you
can say to people if they feel you're
listening not just waiting for them to
stop talking
but deep listening and it's amazing to
me how many journalists don't understand
that because if people think you don't
respect them and again we saw that in
this election it's um you can't tell
them it's dark outside and if they think
you do respect them they'll listen to
you all day my answer thank you please
so much so much of what you said today
resonates with me personally I operate a
solo consultancy by myself and it's
called linkages and I manage global
trade on biotechnology and food around
the world sitting at my desk Singapore
in the evening London in the morning I
am the epitome of what you call diverse
adaptive inclusive entrepreneurial and
resilience in the people I talk to buy
the same and listen to in my ear every
day and yet this election showed me that
the biggest lack of listening or lack of
linkages is with my hometown in Detroit
where so many of the people are older
they don't want the diversity they don't
want to adapt anymore they were told one
job for life they don't want to learn
anymore so there's tremendous
dislocation in my heart I mean my life
how do we bridge this divide that's a
really powerful question and thank you
for that thank you for sharing all of
that and it's a first of all let me say
that I was humbled in writing this book
I worked on longer than any book I ever
did it worked on for three years and the
first thing I had experience on this
book I never had before I felt like I
had a butterfly net and I was chasing a
butterfly and every time I got close it
moved so I had to interview Brian
krzanich the head of Intel three times
and each time just to make sure in
where's law was still going I'd learned
something new duck hunting the founder
of Hadoop three times and often things
changed in between like when I this
thing was going to the press I was
sending them you know paragraphs is this
still correct and so I I know how fast
it's getting and when I say I'm humbled
is that I don't have the answer you know
I really don't but here's what
everything I've learned has taught me
number one we've been here before you
know the most dangerous time to be on
the streets of New York City was when
automobiles were first being introduced
but horses and buggies hadn't been
phased out you could get hit from any
direction okay and we're at one of those
moments if horses could have voted there
never would have been cars okay so you
always have to remember at these moments
and unfortunately those people are hurt
by train by change know exactly who they
are and they protest people who are
benefited from it are too busy garnering
the benefits and you see that asymmetry
in our politics but when it comes to
that that average worker I don't have a
simple answer I wish I did I look for it
but I don't have a simple answer
when the change in the pace of changes
is fast and you have to be a lifelong
learner and I know I was in central Ohio
last week giving a talk and a man came
up to me after my talk he said mr.
Friedman I know all these Trump voters
out here in central Iowa let me tell you
they all want it to be 1965 again other
people have pointed this out the most
important line on the cap of Trump is
the word again okay and believe me I
understand that I mean I live in this
world I thrive on it I am I have nothing
but sympathy for it so I don't have a
simple answer for each person I do have
a macro answer and my macro answer is
not one that any Trump voter want to
hear that is when when you got a really
fast changing moment actually you want
to be as open as possible because you'll
get the signals
first you'll attract the most high-risk
entrepreneurs all right and the same
time you want to be educating everybody
as much as you can be open and educate
everybody as much as you can and then
let the miracle of America happen you
know I was at a conference in September
machardie Rose did and there was a woman
there pretty sure this is what she said
that her job was tagging sharks for
Twitter who knew there was a job tagging
sharks for Twitter you know what I mean
your kid goes off to college comes home
mom dad I want to tag sharks for Twitter
well you know you couldn't be an
ophthalmologist you have to tag sharks
for Twitter um your job I bet five years
ago it didn't exist you know but if you
let it happen and that's what scares me
about Trump I understand the inks that
produced him and I respect it the
penultimate column I wrote before the
selection was addressed to his voters I
said he is indecent man but I know where
you're coming from and he's not going to
get you there because the fort is not
coming back to this country with a
25,000 person factory outside of
Dearborn
it's that factories 2,500 people and 500
robots Warren Bennis said it you know
the moderate factory just has two
employees a man and a dog
the man is there to feed the dog and the
dog is there to keep the man away from
the machines that's where it's going
okay but let me let me share with you
the most important thing I learned in
this book in doing this book and it was
surprising for me and if you'll indulge
me I'll I'll just read a little bit and
we may have to close if we can can't get
to all the questions but I just want to
share this with you because you know
what I learned in doing this book the
thing that stood out everywhere is that
the things that mattered most to people
were the human to human connections you
know Gallup did a giant study Delta
slaughter education polling five years
ago and they studied people who've been
out of college ever there's four or five
years and they asked them are you happy
with the direction of your career and
they called out that group who said yes
and then they drill down
see what they had in common and Gallup
determined they had two things in common
they had had an internship somewhere
along the way in their area of interests
and they had had a mentor who took an
interest in their hopes and dreams
there's such a message in this that
bottle I profile in this book a website
called learn up so you know most big
retail companies today their HR policies
are to weed people out so stay away you
know apply for Old Navy or Walmart they
get millions of them you know over the
year applications they're overwhelmed so
learn up came along to interface between
them and the job applicants you not have
to take a test like a two-hour test on
learner but you know how to fold a shirt
do not operate a cash register do you
know how to deal with a customer and if
you pass that test that we's out already
thousands of people they then make your
job appointment for you but if you go to
their website you'll notice in the upper
right corner is a button it's got a
little smiley face on it it's called the
coach button gets pressed more than any
button on their website and I listed all
the questions the coach gets coach what
do I wear to my job interview coach what
if I'm gonna be late coach what might
the first question be everywhere I
turned it was the human-to-human stuff
that stood out let me just read you this
is from the last pages of my book that's
why when I asked surgeongeneral vivec 14
what was the biggest disease in America
today without hesitation he answered
it's not cancer it's not heart disease
its isolation it is the pronounced
isolation that so many people are
experiencing that is the great pathology
of our lives today
how ironic we're the most
technologically connected generation in
human history and yet more people feel
more isolated than ever this only
reinforces Morty's point that the
connections that matter most are in most
short supply today are the human to
human ones don't get me wrong
technology has so much to offer to make
us more productive
healthier or learned it and more secure
I'm awed by the intelligent assistance I
discovered and research in his book and
the potential it has to live so many
people out of poverty and discover
talent and make it possible for us to
actually fix everything I'm hardly a
technophobe but we will get the best out
of these technologies only if we don't
let them distract us from making these
deep human connections addressing these
deep human longings and inspiring these
deep human energies and whether we do
that depends on all that stuff you can't
download the high-five from a coach the
praise from a mentor the hug from a
friend the hand up from a neighbor
the handshake from a rival the totally
unsolicited gesture of kindness from the
stranger the smell of a garden not the
cold stare of a wall can you imagine how
many jobs there going to be in human to
human connection over Thanksgiving and
I'll stop here this is such an important
question at our Thanksgiving table we
had a friend of ours who's a food
consultant he was hired by a company
called painted I'm not up to and they
have bars where where adults come in and
other people and they paint by numbers
in the bar and they know paint lessons
even better okay whoever thought there'd
be an industry in teaching people to
paint in bars but maybe people so crave
these connections so somebody's going to
own that bar somebody's going to teach
painting there's a good job if
somebody's going to get a massage to the
paint teacher at the end of the day you
know so letting it happen but if you put
up a wall against this we will all
suffer thanks for your question
everything
yeah I'll do two more many as I can in
addition to you reading your new book
what do you recommend is the action plan
for individual citizens if our next
administration enacts anti diversity
anti climate change policies it's a good
question I can tell you what I'm gonna
do as a columnist um you know I'm gonna
go all out you know I kind of spend
fifteen months trying to prevent Trump
from winning right now I'm in a phase
where I'm focused on one thing climate
change because there's a lot of things
he will do that are reversible there's
one thing he can do
that would be irreversible and that is
turn America away from global leadership
on climate and so right now I'm doing
everything I can to sort of you know
push that direction one way or another
but if he if he goes against that for me
it's all that war this is a really
pivotal moment and everyone will have to
find I get to have a column in the New
York Times so I can use that but
everyone will have to find their way to
resist this but we will not we we should
not and I don't think people will they
won't take this stand they won't take
this sitting down
Thanks sorry oh sorry mm-hmm I'm hearing
voices
right to to UM to connect or to Oh
resist right well you know I think you
you really have to do what the other
side did very well
they won state houses all over the
country they gerrymandered districts and
they got they got control of the
Congress and and through that they've
been able to really dominate the
legislative process and unless I'm not
even saying Democrats I think all the
people who feel differently about that
don't get organized you know I'm
actually not a big Facebook user and I'm
not a big Twitter user because I find
they are foe forms of activism because
you talk to people to say well I I
tweeted about it really you tweeted
about it that's like that's like firing
a mortar into the Milky Way galaxy okay
and I have news for you Exxon Mobil
they're not on Facebook they are in your
face they are in the cloak room not the
chat room and they're in the cloak room
with bags of money and so get out of
Facebook into somebody's face and all of
this has all this online stuff has
soaked up so much activism that it's
really given a pass you know to a lot of
people quickly yeah um so in the spring
of 2013 you came and spoke to Eric
triggers seminar and I was one of those
students one of the last things that you
said was you gave a forecast for the
Middle East coming in and you basically
said that it was going to be in chaos
for 50 years
little did we know that summer that the
Egyptian army would throw a coup and
Morsi would be out and that Syria would
still be progressively getting worse
even later
but I'm I was gonna ask kind of how has
that changed considering in light of the
election but also how has that changed
is the world entering 50 years not just
the middle east and the unstable parts
of the world but is the world as a whole
even the developed parts entering you
know some 50 years of chaos so um
I have to confess I can ruin any dinner
party okay
and I do weddings and bar mitzvahs as
well so I don't want to ruin this one
but um I have a chapter on that in the
book and it's built around the
television show Get Smart
you're a little too young to know but it
was a famous spoof on James Bond in the
60s and Don Adams was agent 1980 agent
86 and agent 99 and he worked for an
organization called control and their
worldwide enemy was called Kaos spelled
ka OS and what the chapter is about is
that the world today is actually the
relevant divide in the world is no
longer east west north south communist
capitalist it's between the world of
order and the world of disorder and the
Mediterranean and the Rio Grande are
increasingly a dividing line why is that
because basically the 50 years after
World War Two were a wonderful time to
be an average little state because you
had two superpowers throwing money at
you educating your kids at Patrice
Lumumba University in Moscow or Wichita
State in America they gave you foreign
aid if you were Syria could lose three
wars to Israel they'd rebuild your army
climate change was moderate China was
not in the WTO couldn't take your
low-wage labor and populations were
moderate everyone had a demographic
dividend lots of young people and few
older people in the age of acceleration
all of that is gone now climate change
is hammering these countries they have
demographic deficits a lot of them the
the climate in fact is hammering them so
much they're males are all leaving I
just did a documentary for this forum
National Geographic
Nichiren senegal globalization is
leaving them behind and china's now in
the World Trade Organization so I tell
the story in fact of Egypt I was in
Egypt for Tahrir Square revolution I'm
gone for what for my wife for three
weeks
I'm leaving Egypt I go to Cairo Airport
I'm at the treasure of Egypt souvenir
store at Cairo Airport by my honey a
little something to remind her where her
honey was for three weeks let's see what
do they have here
pyramids ashtrays that my pumpkin
doesn't smoke okay what do they have hey
they have a stuffed camel and if you
squeeze its hump it honks not might my
honey doesn't he have a honking hump
camel so I buy the honking hump camel I
take it to the cash register I turn it
over what does it say at the bottom say
it with me now made in China yeah you're
the lowest wage country in the eastern
Mediterranean there's now a country half
a world away can make your honking
humped camel okay cheaper than you can
ship it and take the profits back home
so what's happening all of these average
states they're actually cracking on and
we're just at the beginning because they
can't handle these accelerations
they're like Caravan homes in a trailer
park a lot of them they're built on
slabs of cement with no basement and no
foundation my accelerations are like a
tornado going through a trailer park
it's starting in West Africa and all the
way to the border of India and the
states the clap first are those whose
borders are primarily straight lines
because they're the most artificial and
it's creating this new divide between
order and disorder that's why I say in
the book mama tell your daughters not to
grow up to be secretaries of state
it's the worst job in the world
okay if Trump comes to you and says he'd
like you to be Secretary of State
tell him you had your heart set on
agriculture okay all right because be
unto whoever gets this job okay to me
it's like Russian Roulette all right
because management weakness managing
state collapse they all think it was
because Obama was a wimp oh they're good
now going to discover that managing
weakness is hell on wheels I better stop
here so we're gonna sign books after
thank you very much
[Applause]
one